negotiating teams have been struggling
to reach a compromise
over fisheries so-called level playing
field rules
for fair competition and on the issue of
how a deal
will be enforced let's listen to what mr
barnier had to say as he left london in
the last hour
good morning mr barnier what will you be
saying to president
vanderlian good morning good morning
we keep calm as always and
if there is still a we will see huh
thank you it's all hopefully a loss mr
barney
missy barney is there any chance of a
deal
okay thanks
if there is still a way we will see you
good forever
our political correspondent rob powell
is in westminster but first let's go to
brussels and our europe correspondent
adam parsons well ever the diplomat i
guess adam not getting much out of
michelle barnier today
uh i have been in that position many
times of trying to cajole mr barnier
into saying
something decisive uh and it is uh it is
tough but he knows that he's going back
to a big meeting
uh with ursula von de lyon and i think
that whatever mr barnier he
says to mrs von delim will be very
illustrative something else i notice in
the background there
were two other people clara martinez
alvaro
paulina hack who are mr barnier's
two deputies that means that effectively
the top negotiating team are going out
of london and heading back
uh to brussels and i think clearly the
uh telephone call between ursula von de
line and boris johnson today
will be crucial what has happened here
is that mr barnier's reached the edge of
his so-called
mandate what is that well it's a set of
guidelines and restrictions that were
given to him on day one
about effectively you can go this far
and no further
and a couple of days ago on wednesday he
was called to a meeting of eu
ambassadors and he was told
that in the opinion of some notably i
have said the french the dutch the the
belgians the danes even the spanish
they thought he was getting too near the
edge of that mandate effectively he was
giving away
too much which tells you quite a lot
that those are significant voices
who think that mr barnier has gone as
far as they want him to
so on the flip side of that if the uk is
saying we need more concessions there is
not
a lot of wriggle room that's why he
can't go any further
that's why it will need uh leaders like
mr vondeline like boris johnson to come
up with a compromise but a warning
that while boris johnson has got
parliament who would have to ratify
anything that he agrees
ursula van der lion has got the leaders
of all those eu member states
notably emmanuel macron in france there
is still
a lot of wriggling and politics and
diplomacy
before a deal can be done and of course
time is
exceptionally short okay adam thank you
let's uh head to westminster then and
rob powell is there a sense in all this
rob that
that the prime minister has got the
stronger hand here because
because of the domestic politics here in
the general election win
in december that he he just cannot be
seen to back down on much of this can he
well i think practically the prime
minister may be
in a stronger position in terms of
getting the brexit deal
practically approved in this parliament
because of course
in the eu as adam's been saying france
could veto it i think realistically
here in westminster when there is a vote
on that deal
it's hard to see it not passing of
course a big part of that is what the
labour party does
and i have to say it's very hard to see
labour opposing that deal because
that would potentially open the door to
a no deal outcome
but it's still politically perilous for
boris johnson he still needs to make
sure he doesn't do a deal that is seen
to sell out
some of the core principles of brexit
that he has been fighting for
over the years and don't forget that
some of the mps here in westminster
who are agitating against the
coronavirus restrictions
are some of the mps that are most in
favor of a more distant relationship
with the european union
as well and i think that's part of the
reason why
yes there is still substantial
differences and there may have to be
movement there will have to be movement
on a political level from boris johnson
and ursula wonderland but at the same
time that's why i think we are seeing
uh the most made out of this pause and
the degree of theatrics and briefing in
the papers this morning
around requests from the french around
the uk pushing back
harsh words against some of those
requests because frankly it works for
both sides it works for the french
because emmanuel macron
needs to show that he is not selling out
his fishing industry
it works for boris johnson as well
because he needs to show that he is
battling
for this brexit deal i think in reality
it's not necessarily a case of who
blinks first both sides will need to
blink
a little bit but it is hard to sell um
any um climb downs to a skeptical home
crowd
in this context i think fudges are more
difficult
and that's why the prospect of no deal
can never be completely ruled out